Long before he was the handsome antihero in
multiple blockbuster movies, he was a cackling
supervillain in a whole bunch of old comics.
And before that, of course, he was an actual
god in mythology.
Here's the untold truth of Marvel's Loki.
Like Thor and Odin, Loki originated in Norse
mythology, where they were all major pre-Christian
deities of the Scandinavian people.
Whereas most Norse gods were big burly guys
with long beards, Loki was always portrayed
as lithe, androgynous, and sneaky.
Although he was the child of Frost Giants,
he was associated with fire and the color
red.
Like fire, he could not be easily contained
and never kept to just one shape.
He and Odin, king of the gods, were blood
brothers, which made him basically a member
of the family no matter how much trouble he
caused.
And as the god of mischief, he caused no end
of trouble.
He also produced monstrous children, who had
their own roles to play in the mythology.
He was the father of Hel, the half-withered
goddess of the underworld, and of Fenrir,
the giant Wolf who bit the hand off of the
god Tyr.
Having once taken the form of a mare, he was
the mother of Odin's eight-legged horse, Sleipnir.
As a prank, Loki once cut all of the hair
off of Thor's wife Sif.
When he got in trouble for it, he made amends
by giving Sif new hair spun of gold, and also
commissioning the dwarves to forge Thor's
famous hammer, Mjolnir.
When Loki proved too troublesome, Odin bound
him under the Earth, where a serpent constantly
drips poison on his face.
He'll be released with the coming of Ragnarok,
the Norse apocalypse, in which all the gods
and monsters will fight to the death.
Loki's first appearance in Marvel Comics was
in Journey into Mystery #85, published in
1962.
This version was created by Jack Kirby and
Stan Lee, who had introduced Thor only two
issues earlier.
Once Thor had become a superhero, it only
made sense to bring in Loki as a supervillain.
Stan Lee freely drew what he wanted from the
Norse myths, while Kirby created a visual
language for Marvel's Asgard — one that
made these super-gods look unlike any Norse
people who'd ever lived, while retaining some
basic iconography.
The new Loki was still slimmer than Thor and
Odin, but now he had black hair and dressed
in green and gold.
Whereas Thor's helmet had wings, Loki's had
large horns.
Instead of Odin's blood brother, Marvel Loki
was his adopted son, making him Thor's brother,
and thus a more equal adversary.
He relied less on shapeshifting than his mythical
counterpart, but made up for it with impressive
skills at sorcery.
Loki became Thor's recurring arch enemy, and
perhaps even more importantly, he was the
very first villain who faced the Avengers.
In fact, he accidentally brought the team
together.
Attempting to mess with Thor from a distance
while imprisoned in Asgard in Avengers #1,
Loki manipulated the Hulk to make people think
he was on a rampage.
That got not only Thor involved, but also
Iron Man, Ant-Man, and the Wasp.
When the four heroes realized Loki was the
true culprit, they teamed up with the Hulk
to battle Loki.
Afterwards, they decided to stay together
as a team, using their combined powers to
protect the world from threats too big for
just one hero.
"Avengers... assemble."
Supervillain or not, Loki was still Thor's
brother.
That made their relationship much more complex
than other heroes and their archenemies.
With Loki, there's some part of him that loves
Thor, and knows Thor loves him back, just
as they both love their father Odin.
On top of that, as more of a mischievous sorcerer
than an evil world-conqueror, Loki was just
too interesting to stay entirely a villain
forever.
So, in time, there were stories where he teamed
up with Thor to face greater threats.
The most notable example was in the 1980s,
during the acclaimed Thor run by writer/artist
Walt Simonson.
In the culmination of a long-foreshadowed
plot, the fire giant Surtur was attacking
Asgard with an army of the dead, and threatening
all the realms beyond.
Odin and his two sons stormed into battle
together, each with a battle cry and that
revealed their priorities in resisting Surtur.
During the "Siege" crossover, Loki sacrificed
himself and died.
He was then reincarnated as an adolescent
boy.
Far more pure of heart than his older counterpart,
Kid Loki had his own series of adventures
in a new volume of "Journey Into Mystery."
At the end of that story, Kid Loki's body
was taken over by a more amoral version of
the character from his previous incarnation
— although he retained the Kid Loki identity.
Kid Loki went on to found a new version of
the Young Avengers, featuring the Kate Bishop
version of Hawkeye, as well as Wiccan, Hulkling,
Marvel Boy, and America Chavez.
Over the course of that series, the other
young heroes gradually came to trust this
young god of mischief, even as Loki himself
struggled with whether or not he was worthy
of that trust.
Late in "Young Avengers," Kid Loki is magically
aged up to around college age.
He remained younger than he'd previously been,
while becoming enough of an adult to interact
with Thor and other adult characters without
being treated like a child.
After the end of "Young Avengers," Loki got
his own comic, titled "Loki: Agent of Asgard."
The idea behind the title was that Loki, no
longer villainous but still amoral, was perfectly
suited to take on secret and sometimes ethically
suspect missions for the rulers of Asgard,
like a one-god black ops team.
It was a perfect premise for the character,
and led to some well-loved stories.
Meanwhile, the Marvel Cinematic Universe was
making Loki more popular than he'd ever been,
with tons of people who'd never read a Marvel
comic becoming big fans of the character.
A huge part of that popularity has to be attributed
to the work of Tom Hiddleston, the handsome
English actor who was cast in the role.
Most of Hiddleston's previous acting work
was on British television, and he was largely
unknown in the United States.
That changed with the release of "Thor" in
2011, in which Hiddleston's Loki was the primary
antagonist.
At the beginning of the movie, Loki is presented
as an ally to his brother Thor, accompanying
the thunder god and his friends on an ill-fated
trip to Jotunheim, home of the Frost Giants.
Things soon break down, however, when Thor
is exiled to Earth and Loki learns he's actually
of the Frost Giant race himself.
As Odin enters a mystical slumber, Loki plots
to take over Asgard.
To do that he has to remove Thor from the
line of succession, even if it means killing
him.
Although he was the villain of the piece,
fans enjoyed his complicated morality as much
as his handsome face.
Just as Loki was responsible for the founding
of the original Avengers in the comics, so
too was Hiddleston's version in 2012's "The
Avengers."
In this version, Loki is wielding a mind-controlling
staff and is working in tandem with an alien
race in an attempt to conquer the Earth.
To stop him, SHIELD brings together Thor,
Iron Man, Captain America, the Hulk, Black
Widow, and Hawkeye.
Once again, Loki's actions lead to the formation
of Earth's greatest super-team, to his regret.
"You are all of you beneath me.
I am a god, you dull creature.
And I will not be bullied by—"
2013's "Thor: The Dark World" finds Loki imprisoned
in Asgard following the events of "The Avengers."
When Dark Elves invade and kill Frigga, mother
of Thor and adoptive mother of Loki, Thor
releases Loki to help defeat the Elves.
While this sequel is frequently criticized,
audiences did get something they'd been wanting:
a less evil Loki.
In fact, that's what Tom Hiddleston wanted
as well.
In a 2013 interview with Total Film magazine,
Hiddleston explained,
"When I met Alan [Taylor, director of 'Dark
World'], he asked me how I thought I could
do Loki again without repeating myself and
I remembered talking with Kevin Feige when
we were on the 'Avengers' promotional tour.
I said, 'OK, you've seen Thor and Loki be
antagonistic for two films now.
It would be amazing to see them fight side
by side."
Loki's duplicity inevitably emerges at the
film's end, of course.
The god of mischief appears to die heroically
in battle with the Dark Elves, but he later
reveals himself as alive and masquerading
as Odin.
By taking his father's form, Loki has achieved
his ambition to rule Asgard.
After appearing in Marvel movies for three
years in a row, Loki had a four-year break
before turning back up in 2017's "Thor: Ragnarok."
Upon returning to Asgard, Thor finds his brother
still impersonating Odin.
The two go in search of the real Odin, who
has returned to Norway, the land where he
once was worshiped, to die.
Upon his death, the Death Goddess Hela is
freed from an ancient imprisonment.
She effortlessly destroys Thor's hammer and
then sends Thor and Loki careening into endless
space.
Loki finds himself on the planet Sakaar and
ingratiates himself to its ruler, the hedonistic
Grandmaster.
Thor soon arrives as well and is forced to
fight as a slave in the gladiatorial arena,
where his first opponent is the Hulk.
Soon Thor and Loki team up with Bruce Banner
and a long-lost Asgardian Valkyrie to escape
Sakaar and return to Asgard to face Hela.
In "Ragnarok," Loki's still not exactly trustworthy,
but he's not a villain at all anymore, and
ultimately proves himself a worthy ally to
his brother as the two escape the destruction
of Asgard with most of the population in a
huge ship.
"I wouldn't worry, brother.
I have a feeling that everything's going to
work out fine."
This new status quo, however, would be sadly
short-lived.
Avengers: Infinity War, released in 2018,
is the climax of the Marvel meta-story that
had been building since the first movie.
It's fitting, therefore, that it begins with
Thanos invading the Asgardian ship and killing
Loki.
The original Avengers villain dies a hero,
at the hands of the ultimate villain who was
secretly using Loki during the invasion of
Earth in "The Avengers."
At this point, Thanos is gathering the Infinity
Stones as part of his mission to wipe out
half of all life in the universe, and none
of the Asgardians are powerful enough to stop
him from gaining the Tesseract, the Infinity
Stone that was at the center of that plot
in Avengers.
Hiddleston's Loki had evolved so far by this
point that it was sad for basically everyone,
not just the Loki mega-fans, to see him strangled
to death by Thanos.
He came so close to being a hero in his own
right, and maybe, there at the end, he was
one.
When he turned up next, however, it was as
the villain he'd once been.
Thanos wins at the end of "Infinity War,"
so in 2019's "Avengers: Endgame," the surviving
Avengers have to go back in time to recover
the Infinity Stones from various points in
history — before they were acquired by Thanos.
As they explain before doing so, each time
they change the past, their actions create
an alternate timeline where things went differently.
One of their time travel destinations is the
aftermath of the invasion in the first "Avengers,"
when Loki had been defeated and taken into
custody.
During the confusion, Loki is able to get
his hands on the Tesseract once more, and
use it to escape to parts unknown.
What this means, of course, is that there's
a Loki out there in the Marvel multiverse
again, despite his death at Thanos' hands
in the main timeline.
But what it also means is that the Loki who
now exists is one who'd never fought alongside
Thor against the Dark Elves or helped save
the other Asgardians from Hela.
This Loki comes directly from a time when
he was very much a villain.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book heroes and villains are coming
soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.